d'accueil maintenant nathalie delon
bonsoir sergi lopez daniel prévost look
n'a donc du film de téchiné et laurent
baffie s'est agi de la sorte à rendre
ailleurs échoue lui répond c'est chez
moi même vous êtes connu pour faire tout
ça alors nathalie vous avez été l'une
des femmes les plus jalouse et du monde
après votre mariage avec alain delon
l'une des mers les plus célèbres de
france après la naissance d'anthony
delon et puis ensuite actrice
réalisatrice productrice écrivain et
aujourd'hui vous sortez une cassette de
conseils de yoga cassettes et dvd qui
s'appelle mon yoga chez studio canal
on va en parler mais d'abord on va
parler un petit peu de votre vie oui
bien alors votre vie est étonnante c'est
un roman votre vie vous êtes né bétheny
rouge t'as au maroc
oui nord du maroc vous faites un tour
d'afrique là ce soir
ce soir ce soir donc un monsieur daniel
prévost dont le père était kabyle vous
vous êtes né à oujda loubna détenait
euro à bruxelles
l'adhésif
viens donc votre mère était originaire
de melilla voilà vous savez plus que moi
c'est une enclave espagnole au nord du
maroc sur la côte méditerranéenne
mon père était pieds noirs d'oran pas du
tout un peu n'est pas mon père pour
franck natali belon qu'il s'attelait
bien le week end dernier c'est bien mais
je vous dis ils étaient pieds noirs de
rang ça vous le saurez dirigeant d'une
entreprise de transport au maroc
effectivement il s'est tiré assez vite
oui quand j'avais huit mois pour ce que
j'en suis à huit vous connaissez pas
qu'on fait l'existant même nom mais
dites-moi si riche ça m'intéresse
vraiment de savoir quel est mon passé
par rapport aux renseignements
c'est vrai comme j'étais petit on vous
interdit la danse parce que vous étiez
pas bonne en maths
oui ça mais j'étais plus grande déjà pas
mal moi c'est l'inversé dans beaucoup
plus fort on enferme et donc vous allez
au collège jusqu'à quoi je crois
troisième dont je voulais et pc c'est ça
et puis après vous épousez un appelés du
contingent originaire du nord de la
france qui s'appelle guy barthélémy guy
barthélémy c'est ça vous décidé de
rester au maroc et lui devient fondé de
pouvoir de l'omnium d'assurance l'omnium
marocain d'assurance je crois que son
père était assureur une fille ensemble
s'appelle natalia ou non mes problèmes
de couple du couple louis fin quoi
erreur de jeunesse y compris même du
couple enfin bon vous parlez de la seule
chose mais c'est très bien vous en
parler parce qu'en fait c'est le jean
bassères on parle pas de lui nos fins
lui
c'est la seule personne au monde j'ai
promis de parler mais enfin on va en
parler puisqu'il est il est le père de
ma fille
voilà oui on arrête avec lui parce que
toute façon c'est pas lui c'est
intéressant c'est pas l'église intéresse
vraiment vous en doutez moins connue que
de longs cheveux blonds guide qui permet
d evry là bas donc vous divorcez anthony
barthélémy on ne connaît pas de mélanie
barthélémy on la connaît pas non plus
donc vous dit mords c'est wild avec guy
barthélémy quand même oui quand même
qu'on en finisse et que ce blaireau
quand lui puis ils gardent l'enfant et
vous partez en france oui enfin on
résumer comme ça on va pas faire mal non
plus merci alors vous avez vous voulez
un coup de main pour répondre mais vous
savez que je peux très bien le faire moi
je suis zen n'oublions pas assez durs et
il a une vieille tendance mais je suis
votre avocat je vous dirai juste je vous
dirai a répondu ou ne répondait d'accord
je vais modérer vos allées procureur
[Musique]
et alors je les ai encore un jour en
1962 vous êtes en france
vous débarquez dans le sous-sol d'une
boîte de nuit parisienne
et vous voyez alain delon oui bon j'ai
pas fait ça parce que je ne les par
d'autres
voilà alain delon avec les amis à lui
galabru au début de drôles de gens avec
l'union on en vient là tout de suite
directe oui à l'époque avait une drôle
de genre
ce sera fait d'accord ce sera fait on
aura fait les fréquentations d'alain
delon ce sera réglé
et alors ils étaient assis sur votre sac
oui c'est un c est donc j'ai assis sur
mon sac j'ai de la force même prix qu'à
fisc sans sac et vous lui dites ça vous
en dirai pas de vous lever un peu pour
que je puisse prendre mon sac et lui
vous réponds prenez le votre sac
j'en ai rien à [ __ ] grande classe et
chic parisien faisait quoi à l'époque je
ne faisais rien chuté à paris et je
faisais des photos si tu peux répondre
la réponse est photographe quoi oui j'ai
photographe
où vas tu montres de marque j'avais
envie d'être photographe oui d'accord
techniquement alors là je vais vraiment
vous demander on a dit vous étiez prête
à tout pour avoir un agrément et ya 10 à
m intervenants étaient légendés j'aurais
dire je n'ai pas eu très facile à sion
avait facilement pour injustes
spécial nathalie oui moi c'est faux
c'est avec ces fausses et c'est un vrai
nom j'ai eu du mal à la voir tout le
malawi exactement là c'est à vous une
majorité l'a effectivement à l'époque ce
qu'il faut dire à nos amis
téléspectateurs qui connaît cette
histoire par coeur
tout le monde croit qui va l'épouser on
est je devais le faire il devait épouser
remich t il votre idylle est resté
longtemps clandestine avec de loin pas
du tout on est parti faire un film sur
le film on peut le dire oui à ma taille
voilà c'est tout de suite on nous a pris
pour faire l'inversé si vous ressentez
c'était incroyable oui moi je trouve pas
bon et les cheveux sur le tournage de la
tulipe noire vous étiez sa jetée secret
à l'époque l'idée d'épouser romy
schneider c'est vrai donc il n'y avait
pas de raison de le mée bon au début
c'était comme ça c'était tranquille
au début on était plus de 30 clients et
ont fait front d'espagne puis ça se
passait très bien vous aider des fêtes
avec fabio le frère de fabiola et puis
on y revenir puis bon le problème s'est
posé qui n'était pas un problème puisque
bon moi je me suis dit je m'en vais et
puis voilà six ans mais auquel il a fait
non un rêve et il lui a dit je suis
désolée voilà voilà
il vous a choisi c'était bon enfin on
n'avait pas vraiment parler avance je
crois que c'était aussi spontané chez
lui que s'il était chez moi
bien oui c'est bien écoute c'est une
jolie histoire
non mais je propose maintenant elle est
belle elle est jolie elle est émouvante
et les romantiques
alors pour être plus courte
laetitia l'isi l'autre votre union
empruntant 64 à la siesta à antibes
j'étais même et ma petite fille répond
pas quand témoin de mariage alors on va
voir si vous allez même info oui le
mariage dans le loir-et-cher s'est
mariée ce jour là il y avait le maire de
témoin voilà on s'est barré on a fait le
mariage et quand on venait pour monter
sur le france les photographes
quelquefois et les informateurs
n'étaient pas les meilleurs donc ils
sont arrivés on est déjà mariées on
partait en voyage de noces est donc là
vous partez hollywood en parc oui et en
maintenance lorsqu'on peut faire mal
oui mais c'est nous tous les verts
le forme et l'amener au temps mais j'ai
pas facile tant exercice pour nathalie
baye l'exercice est servie normalement
ça devrait être facile
vous partez hollywood et l'année anthony
delon rien 64 hollywood parce qu'alain
delon avait un contrat avec la mgm
oui il s'est fait virer il avait dit je
veux l'amérique et belmondo prendre à la
france s'est pas passé exactement ils
sont partagés seront partagés tout ça
voilà alors bon c'est l'époque aussi à
vous étiez un couple assez libre non
enfin lui était très non j'étais très
malade
ouais voilà toute façon donc voir lutter
plus libre que vous peuvent plus vivre y
était plus louis boilot appelons ça
comme ça ouais et était plus infidèles
moi je ne sais pas comment c'est l'un
des problèmes dans le couple quitte
bizarrement qui viennent pas de la main
de long à oui non il ya plutôt de
nathalie pourquoi parce que nathalie que
si vous partez en 66 en vacances à saint
tropez avec marc rich wii qui était
l'ami de la maison celle à 17h chauffeur
au matou faire un peu à tout faire c'est
pas sympathique mais c'est un ami de la
famille voilà ce que je veux dire c'est
que mark vi qui était donc que l'homme à
tout faire un petit peu de la maison
mais elle a surtout il doublait un agent
pour certains films oui doublons lumière
est-ce qu'il l'a doublé auprès de vous
c'est ça l'histoire c'était un accident
un soir attendait ça arrive à l'ijspf là
vous commencez à faire du cinéma jean
pierre melville vous choisi pour jouer
le samouraï
est-ce que toulon était ok pour vous
jouiez dans le samouraï ou est ce que
c'était mais des paroles et on est très
mal passée pendant ton âge mais oui
pourquoi été sévère avec vous
oui mais pas du tout à coup il a pris
tôt d'un coup c'est devenu le problème
c'est à dire que les photographes
étaient là ils avaient envie de faire un
des sujets de problèmes sont arrivés et
voilà il est devenu très désagréable
janvier deux baffes et puis je suis
parti vous n'êtes pas revu pendant trois
mois
voilà même à résidence je peux en maison
de retraite tu peux rentrer à la maison
de retraite
là vous devez déposer là moi je vais me
faire disputer demain j'aurai pas de
dessert c'est là qu'il fait m'arrête là
moi pas moi j'adore le bientôt pour
demain et des surveillants en plus à la
maison rentrée la maison du tibet j'ai
un tilleul d'apprendre à la chambre 76
donc l'avis déposé tous les deux une
requête de divorce
huit premiers j'ai fait une première je
n'ai découvert bien ça s'arrange pas
vous remettez en sang mais ça s'arrange
pas parce que vous habitez tous les
trois avec ce stefan markovic
comment c'est possible ça c'était il y
avait georges beau mais ces familles en
effet beaucoup beaucoup de gens dans
cette maison dormait pas tous ensemble
mais on avait et trois étages
il ya david anthony ce dernier avec la
teneur voilà oui et donc stefan markovic
habilité en bas et il y avait les
bureaux il ya georges roubia voilà mais
qu'est ce qui a précipité votre
séparation à ce moment-là 68 mai 68
pourquoi pas s'ils avaient monté un
espèce de club si j'ose dire avec le
briani ouais bah voilà un qui est
vraiment c'est un peu choquant et
j'étais pas tout à fait ok avec ses
idées donc je les lis bon bah écoute moi
toute façon j'en ai marre d'être dans
cette baraque je me casse qui m'aime me
suive
voilà les personnes vous assurez des psy
m'a suivi je suis reparti ouais et puis
marque ovi qui a été assassiné oui
vaches les découverts en argentine on
est toujours des couverts en argent
c'est à 10 en argent
c'est vous qui l'avez découvert les
défauts que je n'ai pas non non je les
découvertes dans le sur le journal en
partant de paris à londres où se tourne
et je vivais et j'ai découvert que
monsieur avait été assassiné et quand je
suis arrivé georges borg le fameux
georges bombe si vous en parlez ce qui
est le parrain anthony m'a téléphoné
pour me maquiller nathalie stefan
markovic a été assassiné on n'a jamais
su qui avait assassiné marque ovi qu'on
a on a connu la sphère marcovici
histoire de chantage avec madame
pompidou etc
on n'est jamais déçu mais on sait pas on
n'a jamais su la vérité
ce qu'on sait c'est que vous avez été
entendu 14 heures par la police et alain
delon aussi mais jamais su qu'il avait
assassiné au format reconnu
si vous le saviez vous dirai pas ce soir
tu te sens vraiment pas non sens pas ne
me sentais pas donc elles sont là
préparez vous vous gardez anthony delon
le nom d'alain delon aurait demandé de
le garder oui oui parce que vous étiez
d'accord certains craignant dira
nathalie dit de l'ong voilà déduit sans
vagues merida mairie d'arqués tu es là
pour l'épauler on remarque bien et vous
vous conduire est intéressant quand ils
passaient l'histoire de france vous
continuez vous continuer le cinéma vous
oui 25 films en 15 ans pas mal et là
vous écoute avec easy témoin bien quand
anthony à 14 ans il décide d'aller vivre
avec son père et vous vous dites bas
j'ai plus de raison d'être là et vous
partez au liban voilà vous faites un
scénario assez bons appels qu'ils
appellent ça un accident vous produisez
que vous tournez le film est produit par
chris blackwell
oui hélas donc vous vivez et chris
blackwell à ce moment là eh oui ouais
enfin jb oui c'était l'homme de ma vie
voilà il faut dire à nos amis chris
blackwell c'est le producteur de bob
marley etc etc
grand bonhomme de la musique vous étiez
une des rares femmes blanches accepté je
n'ai pas quand j'ai connu bob j'étais
très bon ça va avec la jamaïque j'ai
découvert et bob marley me toucher la
masse qui étaient très rares
ouais en tout bien tout honneur
normalement il ne serre pas la main des
femmes blanches et des bus lancement des
frappes des femmes en général oui mais
c'est quand même un peu une briseuse de
ménage non pas du tout dites moi qui
viens vous l'appliquez l'exotique et
delon et romy schneider la pauvre omis
on a je ne connaissais pas attendu les
filles n'étaient pas mariés ben voyons
il allait se marier quand même en fait
c'était pas mon problème
mon problème vous êtes attaqué richard
burton aussi pas du tout il s'est
attaqué à moi vous êtes en hongrie pour
tourner un film barbe bleue 72
elizabeth taylor qui fête ses 40 ans
elle vous apparaît vite évidemment pas
folle 1
et il faut dire que burton villa
effondré j'ai lu la bio de burton burton
était effondré par la mort de son frère
y fort il prenait de l'alcool n'était
pas comme ça et puis finalement il a
accepté vos avances c'est vrai qu'ils
habitent taylor est venu vous sortir du
vide de burton en remettant un coup de
poing non c'est dans la biographie de
burton arrêt nous pourrait après dans
les escaliers quand on revenait du
tournage mais on ne s'est pas
complètement fou ce que j'avais quand
même hôtel éteignez chez
c'est aussi est ce que vous étiez au
courant de l'existence de ari boulogne
que nous avons reçu ici
le fils d'alain delon et de nico qui est
né en 68 antilles à la période où vous
avez rencontré de long est ce que vous
connaissez son existence oui avant que
quand j'ai rencontré alain oui je sais
très bien son existence puisqu'il
n'était pas son fils et qu'elle s'est
pointé au studio en disant voilà ton
fils oui et vous pensez que c'est passé
par oui ou par non voulait non ça va pas
vous en pensez vous dites donc vous êtes
au courant de l'existence d'un rue très
bien je vous dit ce n'est pas le fils
d'alain devant voilà je dis ce qui était
vrai c'était pas maintenant si nous
pouvons prouver le contraire
maintenant je pouvais rien du tout je
vous demande pourquoi vous l'aimez bien
j'ai de la tendresse pour lui une
certaine compassion pour ce que la vie
qu'il a vu mais je vous avez vu tout
petit but et je ne pense pas sur le fils
d'alain delon
mais attendez je n'étais pas là à ce
moment là ce soir là non non avant
employés
[Musique]
à nîmes l2 afin de saint-etienne qui me
dit mon père besset l'edf mais chaque
fois que tu fais couper la lumière à
toute la france et une chute de tension
sur le réseau
moi je voudrais rentrer
au cherche midi
même si
et là je dis moi je cherche mais les
buteurs dernière
c'est beau
sur moi et la caméra c'est sur moi je
voudrais me voir à l'antenne voilà je
vais juste vous dire que je partirai
quand on me demandera gentiment je te
demanderai pas gentiment
donc je reste tellement que vous soyez
mise au yoga la transition était là
c'est vraiment pas un accident c'est t'y
comprends d'après une vie pareille à
bronzer john camm donc vous puisse
arriver ça n'a juste juste raison j'ai
dû faire pas mal choses et venir me
rejoindre sur les hauteurs
moi aussi je ne voulais oui oui je vous
disais je déménage donc c'est comment on
fait nathalie delon
vient alors ça s'appelle mon yoga
étirements respiration relaxation
c'est en cassette et en dvd vous dit en
parlant de yoga ceni une philosophie ni
une religion mais simplement on apprend
comment respirer commande et vous
apprendre à respirer ce que titien est
bien son nom on va progresser fiable
mais quand je disais mission on apprend
restait à l'effi est ce qu'elles doivent
s'allonger matelly est ce qu'un seul
angers mais ça respire et avait des
pauvres genou à genou s'il vous plaît
voilà ça fait du bien de dire ah je dois
des pièces des gros nichons saclay sahin
bas c'est toi qui l'a dit que c'est moi
bien utiliser mois donc asseyez vous sur
wii et qu'est-ce que mickael face d'un
preneur comme soit inspiré aux fans en
rentrant dans trois grands très inspiré
par le haut par le nez toujours l'oeil
expert et pardonnés s'ils sont belles
attendez je me fais aussi ça vous
dérange pas mais normalement on aspire
en expert par le nez voilà vous détendez
détendez vous et voilà vous voyez
regardez correspondent elles n'ont donc
pas à ma parcelle respire avec le vase
était moche à vendre est plein
est ce qu'elle va faire des étirements
là mais oui pour intégrer c'est comme en
celle que tout le monde sait comment les
écraser sur le dos sur le dos au but et
consorts le dos les filles tu vas
bientôt sur le dos les genoux sur la
poitrine les genoux sur la poitrine elle
est bien cette cassette brésil
entouré vos genoux avec vos bras entouré
bogies avec vos bras spiraux
profondément mais ce qu'elle est
profondément blessé les jambes derrière
la tête
ça c'est après ces temps derniers mois
c'est vrai qu'on s'est bien détendu et
un vent dé la monnaie alors reposer
maintenant voilà bien une très jeune
changer d'étalon parfaire le talent
ombrelle handisport inspiré en levant le
bassin baissé le plus vite
inspirez expirez non non vous allez trop
vite s'ils comprennent rien
ben oui mais attendez il faut qu'elle
voit la cassette desquels la chine au vu
des cassettes
voilà vous inspiré par les expiré et
reposé doucement la colonne vertébrale
c'est vrai qu'elles peuvent y arriver
nathalie oui mais bien c'est tout le
monde peut d'y arriver mais très vite
c'est très bien il faut juste rester
comme ça c'est bien rester comme ça
voilà donc vous êtes bien voilà vont
rester comme ça on continue nous met
d'accord très bien donc ça s'appelle
effectivement pour y jouer au yoga avec
votre femme ça s'appelle mayorga par
nathalie delon donc c'est des étirements
des mouvements des autres
bien très bien les finales si nous vous
aidons les personnes si absolument bien
alors nathalie delon on peut dire la
vérité vous à vidéo vous avez eu débat
dans votre vie ben oui nos machines
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bien eh bien il a une long interdit au
bendern ce que vous préférez en vous ma
sérénité nouvelle en l'étant business
sérieux ah oui au sérieux enfin bref
j'ai dit la vérité bien sûr cergy a dit
tout le monde a franchi ce qu'on a
appris qu'il était sado-maso chaque
joueur homosexuel et pire catalan est ce
que vous détestez en vous je suis un peu
maso ouais vous aussi oui moi aussi ce
qui vous plaît le plus dans la vie le
bonheur ce qu'il vous plaît le moins
dans la vie non pas le malheur non ça va
trop loin près c'est trop loin de la
connerie quoi le plus beau moment de
votre vie vous avez eu en tenue oui un
des plus beaux mais c'est plus fort
c'est plus fort le pire quand elle a su
qu'ils restent à la maison pas encore
les bandes noires il a le pire n'est pas
encore arrivé oui c'est bien c'est la
chance d'un oui ce qui a tout changé
dans votre vie
la rencontre avec alain on peut dire
plus que le yoga ce qui n'a rien changé
dans votre vie
elle ment divorce votre plus belle
histoire d'amour
bah c'est alors oui oui et marc marc
bourrel votre histoire d'amour la plus
minable
bernard menez
ah bon non ce que vous préférez dans le
sexe est bien bonne baguette de dire
c'est vrai ouais est ce que vous
détestez dans le sexe la différence mais
ça n'arrive pas souvent mais c'est vrai
que c'est quand y'en a pas voilà et pour
être sûr de ne rien rater de in a
l'habitude abonnez vous y mettez un peu
de bleu